I was thinking last night and this
morning that they had a few more hours
to decide if they were going to postpone
it and and I think that the pictures
we've seen the images and then the
decision that there would be another day
of action on Tuesday during mistake is
it probably tipped the balance for the
Elysee thinking and made them pick up
the phone to 10 Downing Street which is
of course what they did in the first
instance so no I think it's very sad I
don't see it as a major embarrassment I
think it is a reality check of what's
going on in the streets of France at a
time when people are feeling obviously
very angry there's a lot of trouble a
lot of writing a lot of
bonfires and things around the place I
think it it makes sense and it looks as
though both our own king and the
president of France will want to
reinstate this visit as soon as they can
um are you surprised how late it was
canceled or or again is that not really
effective for embarrassment they just
left left as much time as they could
I suspect that they were hoping that it
would be possible to keep the visit
intact even if they had to change the
venue of the banquet from of Si with all
its historical significance and so on in
the Hall of Mirrors to a venue in Paris
as I say I suspect that it was the
announcement there will be another day
of action on Tuesday together with the
fact that overnight there were you know
more than a hundred French policemen
injured a lot of arrests a lot of
trouble probably made the president and
his staff think you know what this is
supposed to be a real showcase this is
supposed to be a celebration
of a revitalized refreshed visit with
our nearest neighbor and we don't want
it to go wrong there's too much risk
involved and so let's put it off so
these things can be done at the last
minute I think you couldn't have left it
much longer than this morning if you're
going to undo all the detailed planning
that's gone into a visit of this kind
but I think everybody will understand
um I just wanted to flip it round again
on this topic of whether it's
embarrassing for the French government
or not if this was a visit to the UK by
a foreign head of state but we were
fearful that protests would be taking
place in some level that that could be
disruptive to the visit or embarrassing
uh to to the visitor that that was
coming would would we not be asking
questions about suppressing free speech
and and and and the like or not I mean
I'm reminded of President Trump's visit
in in 2018 to the UK where there was a
lot of protests but that wouldn't lead
to a cancellation
no the president Trump visit I I recall
a lot of care was taken to keep him away
from lots of people and quite a lot of
the travel and the venues were out of
town which I'm not mistaken the point
about this is that it was a state visit
which the 2018 one I don't think was
correct me if I'm wrong and it was a lot
of it was to be public uh it was to be a
public celebration you would have had
you know horses in the champs-elysees
and imagine if people had thrown
firecrackers at them and there'd been
all sorts of trouble you know that would
have been the story rather than as I say
a celebration of a very important
relationship after a few years when our
relationship has been pretty bad of
course if you're right if the ball had
been on the other foot so to speak who
would be another foot we wouldn't have
wanted to cancel a really important
visit and to the extent possible you
mitigate the risks but I think in this
case and Paris is a country where
sometimes when things really do get a
flare-up Don Larry you in the street as
they say you just have to face up to the
reality and and draw a sensible
conclusion I think it's about risk
management and the risk I'm afraid of
this going wrong of reducing the wrong
results was such that it was best to
postpone I'm also interested in your
perspective given that you work so
closely with the the now King well how
disappointed he will be and how involved
he would have been in picking France as
his first big official foreign trip
given that of course now it won't be the
first because her he still is Con doing
the part of the trip to Germany so
France I guess slips down down would
that be a disappointment to him and
would he be involved in that
you know I think it will be a
disappointment uh it was made clear even
without an official announcement uh you
remember shortly after the queen died
that uh the king hoped that his first
visit abroad would be to France
um and I think he uh other members are
all family British people actually were
very touched by the tributes that were
paid to the queen to the royal family in
general by the French people despite the
fact that we've had a few years of
frankly difficult politics since the
brexit referendum uh with France and I
think the the king probably wanted to
respond to that
um
there is an important relationship with
France which is not just about the heads
of government prime minister and
president it's important also that our
head of state our king queen as it was
and the President also have a
relationship and we have a king who's
been in France 35 times on official
visits in his career so far this would
have been his first ever State visit to
a country which is very fond which he
knows well so I'm sure I'd be
disappointed but you know life goes on
he will go to Germany with the queen
consort instead on Wednesday and a
spectacular I'm sure a visit to France
will be reinstated when conditions make
that possible will he be disappointed I
would imagine that he would be but he
will of course have understood uh the
the Judgment reached by the two
governments because he acts of course on
the judge on the advice of the British
government and the two governments I'm
sure reached a conclusion pretty quickly
together this morning that it was best
to put things up and just finally sir
Peter Well gauge for us your assessment
of the relationship between the two
countries that the governments rather
than uh the heads of state do you think
that is much improved all of a sudden
it feels to me that it's a lot better
yes because we have a prime minister now
who has decided to try to fix the
problems that he can fix of the
post-brexit relationship uh one thing
he's done is of course delivered on the
the Northern Ireland protocol that has
begun to unblock a number of other parts
of our relationship with the rest of the
European Union including with France
we've got a good relationship on defense
and on intelligence and so on there is a
new understanding on the small boats
bringing all those tragically sad
refugees across the channel which we
didn't have before who knows whether
it'll work but there's obviously
political will for that and I think uh
Rishi sunai clearly wants to make the
relationship with our nearest to most
important neighbors work a lot better
whereas dare I said some of his
predecessors seem to be more interested
in in blaming them for things that have
gone wrong in the implementation of
brexit rather than trying to make the
relationship work as well as it could
and I think that this prime minister has
a different attitude